hey what's up guys mkbhd here so there
are a lot of phones competing for your
money this holiday season and there are
three pretty major contenders here the
samsung galaxy nexus the samsung galaxy
s3 and the lg nexus 4. they all have
slightly different displays designs and
materials they all come in at slightly
different price points and are all
available on different carriers so
they're basically very different devices
in a lot of ways but yet there is a lot
similar between them as well so this
video is geared to help you make your
decision which one will you pick let's
go ahead and find out all right so the
first thing we're going to start off
this comparison with with the nexus 4
here on the right hand side is with none
other than its older brother the galaxy
nexus so you can kind of see sort of an
evolution of the nexus design here but
we're going to go ahead and start off on
the outside of these devices with the
hardware and this is a comparison for
those of you who are considering maybe
upgrading from the galaxy nexus to the
nexus 4. you get the 5 megapixel camera
on the galaxy nexus and an 8 megapixel
on the nexus 4 and this is definitely an
upgrade you can definitely see a
difference in image quality i would
compare the nexus 4 to something like
the galaxy s3 in terms of image quality
so it's pretty much up there with the
best of the 8 megapixel smartphone
sensors down at the bottom here you also
have a bit of a speaker change you have
a very small speaker on the galaxy nexus
and you have a slot speaker on the nexus
4 but i got to be honest neither of
these speakers is particularly good
especially for watching videos or
particularly gaming media isn't very uh
high quality it's very loud on the new
nexus but it's definitely going to be a
little bit tinier the galaxy nexus has a
removable plastic back so you can access
the smaller battery but it's removable
and there is external storage with the
new nexus it is sealed in you get a
glass back and you guys already know
that there's only an 8 gigabyte or 16
gigabyte model so you have no expandable
storage with the nexus 4. you can see
here they're both running android 4.2
jelly bean and i guess to make that more
obvious we'll go into the quick settings
here and you have all the same controls
on either device there's no difference
here you're going to get the same very
timely updates with the lte galaxy nexus
you won't get quite as fast updates you
have to wait for verizon to push them
but you still get very fast updates from
the gsm version of both of these nexuses
the displays you'll notice are a little
bit different the years in super amoled
display on the samsung galaxy nexus from
samsung and lg uses an ips display and
there are some real differences here
especially in the contrast levels and
brightness levels on the galaxy nexus
you're going to get higher contrast much
blacker notification bar deeper blacks
higher contrast and overall much
punchier colors and you notice that if
you have a black wallpaper it just
doesn't even light the pixels up it is
completely black down here with the uh
software buttons here so it looks like
almost part of the bezel which is really
cool it doesn't look bad on the galaxy
or on the new nexus 4 but you'll do note
that it's not perfectly pitch black even
though the blacks are pretty deep i
won't complain about the blacks but
contrast levels aren't quite as insane
as they are on the samsung device that
being said if you take a look at the
brightness this device gets a lot
brighter than the galaxy nexus when we
pump up the volume all the way up here
it gets super super bright and that's
really nice for reading outdoors and
just reading just general usage in
higher bright lit environments so if
you're checking out a phone and you've
had trouble reading amoled displays
outdoors or if you're concerned with a
slightly bluish tint that you might find
on a phone like this you might want to
consider going with the ips display now
they are very similarly priced but
you'll notice in terms of experience
they have very different internals the
new nexus 4 here on the right has a
snapdragon s4 pro while the one on the
left is a 1.2 gigahertz dual core this
is a quad core processor and i'm gonna
be totally honest this is the fastest
snappiest android experience of any
phone i have ever used if you haven't
already seen my full review of it of
course that link is down below the like
button on this video i am a big fan of
the speed of this phone it has two gigs
of ram it has high quality graphics quad
core processor at 1.4 gigahertz 1.5 it
is the highest end chip you can buy and
that's going to get you the fastest
performance you're going to be able to
game really easily it's just it handles
everything all around like a boss with
acceptable battery life on the galaxy
nexus i'm not going to say this is a
slow phone by any means because with
project butter this phone got a lot
faster on android 4.2 so frame rates are
still very high but they're obviously
not not quite as snappy as the new nexus
4. i'll put it that way you can also see
the extra row of icons but basically it
is still a solid experience and it's
definitely a phone you could probably
get away with using for the next year
again battery life is acceptable not the
best but it's definitely pretty uh
pretty high up there you're not going to
get the most insane battery life out of
the nexus 4 despite its lack of lte and
that's probably the biggest difference
between these two particular phones i'm
holding here the verizon galaxy nexus
versus the variety or the lte or non-lte
nexus 4. you're going to get some
differences in terms of speed here i'm
not saying hsba plus is slow but you're
going to get lower att or t-mobile data
speeds versus verizon so if you're
thinking about ending your verizon
contract think about what you do on your
phone do you do a lot of web browsing do
you do a lot of video watching things
that require a lot of data if so you
might want to stick with a verizon phone
like the galaxy nexus but if you don't
maybe you just do a lot of social
networking maybe twitter a lot or maybe
google plus a lot share a lot of photos
maybe you don't use the most data ever
or you're not too concerned about your
data streaming speeds the hspa plus on
the nexus 4 will probably do you pretty
well so as promised the second phone
that we're going to be comparing the
nexus 4 to is the samsung galaxy s3
which is a very popular device right now
and right off the bat you see a
difference in device size so the
footprint of the galaxy s3 is a little
bit taller and it is just a little bit
wider just a hair but it's not that
noticeable where you do notice the
difference is the thinness so when
comparing these side by side the galaxy
or the galaxy s3 is a little bit thinner
it's a little bit more round as well but
basically the main difference between
these two devices is again this device
has lte on verizon if you want it this
device does not have lte this device on
the left here the galaxy s3 has a
plastic removable back and that's going
to get you again access to the battery
and access to additional storage if you
want it the camera's on the back now
though and a lot of the other hardware
of the galaxy s3 is higher priced but
it's upgraded to match the nexus 4. so
you get a dual core processor in the
united states if you want international
you get a quad core galaxy s3 you also
get an 8 megapixel camera on both these
guys and turning them around
the speaker again is comparable this
one's a little bit louder on the galaxy
s3 again the slot speaker on the nexus
isn't the best but you also have
the notification bar on both these
devices it's at the bottom on the nexus
and it's at the top on the galaxy s3
there is also a hardware button on the
galaxy s3 some people might like that
some people might not but you got to
know that this is not a nexus device out
the box so when you buy a galaxy s3
you're going to be getting touchwiz and
you're going to be getting slower
updates to android so if that's
important to you you might want to go
with a nexus one of the two nexuses or
if they're not as important to you you
can probably go with touchwiz on top of
this galaxy s3 there's an amoled display
on the left and an ips display on the
right and again the deep blacks look
insanely good on the galaxy s3's display
and they don't look quite as black on
the lg nexus 4's ips display but again
it's not all that bad this is also one
of the fastest android phones out there
right now it's not running stock android
out the box
but in the end this you can do something
called uh root and end up making this a
little bit nicer than the nexus 4. and
i'll explain to you basically in a super
nexus video that i did not too long ago
that link is down below in the
description you can root this phone and
put stock android on it so you can run
almost the exact same software as
running on the nexus 4 and you'll get
all the benefits of that amoled display
of that larger display of that nice
camera of that removable back you'll get
basically an upgraded nexus 4 but that's
if you're willing to go through the
software process but basically if you're
comparing it to the galaxy s3 you can
compare this to basically any of the ir
high-end phones on the market so that
applies to the htc one x that applies to
the galaxy note 2
maybe not the other sealed back phones
but you get the advantage of having
up-to-date hardware and if you root you
can have up-to-date software but that's
basically it for the head-to-heads with
these two devices uh if you're
interested you can check out more
information in the description i'll have
links to other helpful videos and things
to help you guys out but that's
basically it this is the nexus 4 the
galaxy s3 and we take a look at the
galaxy nexus and of course the high-end
phones are battling for your money this
holiday season so if you enjoyed this
video feel free to uh plus one or give a
thumbs up down below if you want to see
more videos like this feel free to
subscribe as there are many more on
their way thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you